[Music]
one day I got a call from Evans a pouran
friend of mine and colleague and
composer at MIT and he said that he was
approached by Sanjay Sarma of open
learning to see if he could create some
kind of musical experience for MIT
virtual commencement just to fool around
with it I just kind of wrote something
really quickly just as a basic proof of
concept you know like how about
something like this
[Music]
and send it to Iran he went oh that's
perfect let's just used which never
happens it was really important to me
that we could have every person
contribute and of course this is a
musical project which means that
probably people who are musicians are
going to feel more comfortable
but we really wanted everyone to feel
comfortable contributing and so we did
an analysis of all of the notes in the
piece that Evan wrote and figured out
which ones would be harder to sing but
which ones might be easier to sing and
so on the submissions website anyone can
pick their level of comfort or
experience and then the system
automatically gives them notes to sing
that are appropriate for their comfort
level everyone who submitted out out
there you don't really have to worry
about whether you were singing exactly
in tune we kind of fixed it for you
[Music]
[Music]
okay
hey everyone getting the team together
to make it happen was essential and was
quintessentially MIT because I think MIT
is one of the few places where you think
of a project like this and you go okay
we're gonna need you know a composer
working with Joel Ralston we're gonna
need fantastic audio people we're gonna
need the most amazing coder on the
planet they're gonna be fantastic web
developers
you're gonna need fantastic video people
you don't need fantastic communications
people to get the word out and all these
people are a phone call away or an email
away and will answer and everybody is
devoted to MIT theses are still coming
on I still remember the first meeting
when we started to get people together
and we're talking about the website that
we would need to get input from
participants and we're all going oh god
that sounds so complicated that's gonna
take you know two weeks just to get that
up and hike just very softly says I'll
have it ready by 2:00 p.m. tomorrow and
then he did one of the neat things is we
had this feedback box and we intended
this to be like this piece of the
website did not work well but actually
instead in the feedback box we started
getting these comments like hey man this
is awesome
way to go Iran hooray for MIT it was
incredible to see that people really did
contribute
you could see every minute or so every
30 seconds or so at the peak it would be
another clip showing up one of the
really wonderful things I noticed was
that people were being creative with how
they submitted and we also saw a lot of
families coming together and it was
really wonderful to see a sense of
community even when we were just asking
for a single dope
if this were just a song that was sung
it wouldn't be quite as interesting as
challenging really fascinating part of
this project has been the effort of
putting the video together with the
music the visuals for the piece were
left really open-ended which was
wonderful and the idea of sort of a
journey came to mind the idea of sort of
creating this journey that the student
takes every day as part of this piece
really I thought resonated with this
idea of students going through their
their commencement and through their
actual academic journey there's a part
of the piece that I wrote where the
music kind of ascends when I wrote it I
wasn't thinking of anything it was just
something I felt it was needed basically
at that time but what was really magic
to me was what Clayton first showed us
that moment the camera crosses NASA
Abbott would walk up the stairs into the
infinite corridor
[Music]
and it matches the music absolutely
perfectly and it made the music work it
got you know it was the magical moment
for me that's the real sign to me of a
great collaboration when you do what you
do as well as you can and then somebody
else does what they do and they take
what you've done and turn it into
something bigger than what you thought
it could be there's a discussion early
on about trying to hide some some MIT
Easter eggs inside the piece at the time
I was thinking you know it'd be good
just to get the piece done let's worry
about you strikes later on but we did
put a four different moments inside the
piece and we're excited that people
might find them and share those I think
the the most heartwarming part of this
project to me is the fact that it really
is the voices of the graduates of 2020
and these are MIT students who have put
their heart and their expression into
this musical piece and therefore this is
really a creation of the students by the
students and for the students
[Music]